from my personal experience anything you
want to know this man right here
especially when it comes to science has
the answer
okay so they'll have it an answer
whether or not it's the answer that's a
way to be determined please you're
ruining what I believe that okay I
thought dismantle your bleep my whole
world is crumbling I need to believe in
you man hey
[Music]
times are widely misunderstood okay
all right I will I will say the next
thing I say may be mind-blowing to you
okay okay the tide doesn't actually come
in and out what happens is there is a
bulge of water two of them on opposite
sides of the earth caused by the Sun in
the moon and Earth turns inside that
bulge mm-hmm so when this when we say
the water rises and falls tidally what's
happening is we are rotating into the
Bulge and then out of the Bulge
so the Bulge is already today already
there and all we kind of do is pass
through the pass through and the water
gets high and it gets low so we're stuck
with language from our own perspective
rather than language of what's actually
happening it's simpler that way to say
that water goes in it now it's simpler
to say the sunset rather than earth
rotated such that our angle of view on
this stationary Sun fell below our local
horizon right this is yes sunset is far
more poetic yeah just you go to the
sunset tables you know to look this up
yeah because you can't say to a girl hey
how'd you like to go and watch the
angular momentum of the earth cause the
Sun to disappear behind a horizon hello
would you go let's look at just the
earth in the moon for the moment okay
okay many people think that moon is what
causes it no Luna is two-thirds of the
time okay okay the Sun is another is
two-thirds three-quarters depends on
their distance the Sun has its own tides
on the earth wait in fact the tides that
the moon raises on earth are the same no
matter the phase okay no matter the
phase of the Moon whether some people
believe that when you have a full moon
what you have is a higher tide because
you have a full or moon you do have a
higher tide oh but the tide that the
moon raises on the earth is basically
the same no matter its face no matter
its face what happens at full moon
is that the sun's tides add to the
moon's tides precisely
oh snap we talking about a tired assist
from the tide assist Oh a tide assist
and so that's why that coincides with
the full coincides with with the full
moon because a full moon you got the
moon here right earth and the Sun
everybody lines up that's what it is in
fact we have a word for that it has the
most number of letters when scripted
it's a dip below the line okay I know
that's a weird weird record to hold
right weird it's syzygy so Sid disease
when three or more objects come into
alignment in you know cosmically so you
have the moon the earth the moon will
have the same tide it would at any time
right now it lines up with the Sun right
they add together you get the highest
tides at full moon and new moon
so not ask you when would you get the
lowest start when the Sun is not lined
up okay let me quantify that so when the
Sun is at 90 degrees the Sun is pulling
this way and the moon is pulling that
way and the two waves basically cancel
it they try to cancel one of the to have
the lowest side it's called the neap
tide they leap leap leap leap tide look
at this it's not the moon it was the Sun
all the time it was the Sun all the time
see you think we could see well and so
when people say I feel the extra tidal
forces from the moon when it's full it's
just [ __ ]
ah so just want to clear that up okay so
I didn't have an explained tide yet let
me take two minutes to explain that week
okay that was just about the moon and
the Sun and the fact that the Bulge
so that's right so watch what happens
what cannot go forth so let's just look
at Earth in the moon for the moment the
side of the earth that's closest to the
moon feels a stronger gravitational pull
of the moon then the side of the earth
that's right okay right the closer you
are the source of gravity is stronger is
that for right is that for so that's
true for everything right no matter one
is always exerting a gravitational pull
on the earth on the earth yes and
there's a difference in the
gravitational pull from one side to the
other okay because of there's a
difference it means it's pulling this
harder than that
right if you do that you end up
stretching okay so the water stretches
along the line that the moon's tidal
forces are pulling that's yeah okay it's
a stretching force right all right and
by the way we don't call that earth yoga
yes and now okay
downward dog so it does that for
anything water happens to be more
responsive to this force because if
liquid at night but it also raises tides
on the solid earth but you don't see
that right how does you know in a small
much smaller and so but it does it
basically for everything and so that's
how you get a tide that's how you get
the tides and so and so that bulge is
always there but the Sun is messing with
it right okay so as the moon orbits the
earth and the tidal bulge sort of
Dracula with the moon right and the Sun
is like starting its force is Florent
Aeneas Li simultaneously and it's either
lines up or doesn't Wow okay how much
brain you got left to get I don't know
man we about this okay so no watch I
guess I don't have it so it turns out we
are rotating faster then the time it
takes the moon to go around the earth
okay so a day is shorter than a month
okay all right
so so we are actually if you the viewer
are the moon and you're trying to raise
this bulge okay I'm dragging the Bulge
ahead of you because I'm rotating faster
that's right okay so so the Bulge is not
actually exactly aligned no it's over
here it's it's it's like that way and
then that angle if you're pulling a
watch so what what so it's because I'm
rotating sin a watch so the moon is
actually tugging on that bulge trying to
line it back up right and it does that
against the wishes of our rotation right
so the tidal bulge
the moon is slowing down the rotation of
the earth so are you telling me that
that's why we have leap seconds Dave
so the tides are not only responsible
for what we perceive as water going in
and out it's just it's responsible for
the slowing down with orientation of the
earth and the earth has been slowing
down ever since the moon has existed
okay and we know this because there are
mollusks that have certain features in
their in their physical body that is
that attract to the phases of the Moon
okay really
yes okay so the track to the how when
they're stuck on the ground versus when
they're in the tide comes and gets them
okay there's a record of the cycling's
of the Moon of the tides and a watch we
also have other evidence for how many of
those cycling's occur in a calendar year
great and back then there were more of
them okay which meant that earth rotated
faster back then yes so the moon has
been slowing us down ever since or the
earth is just getting really tired and
then the people say if the moon affects
the water and the water is made of order
and we're mostly watered what doesn't
the moon affect us uh-huh because when
80 to 70 percent more it's a common it's
a natural thing to think of it's just
when people say that people act weird
during the full moon yeah yeah even
though the moon's tides are not strong
around there okay it's really the whole
circle baby right right yes I serve but
you want to explain lunatics the really
son of Texas so let's say so way better
that's what they were solar to a solid
team so here's the thing
the moon creates a tidal force across
your skull
okay I did not know that yes of course
anything right this side of your head is
closer to the moon there this side of
your head okay but we can calculate what
that difference in gravity is across
your head really it's not very much
yeah man wait I do that sometimes you
got a little so you can calculate how
much that is and then you can compare it
to other things that are operating on
your head like you go to sleep there's a
pillow sitting right here
okay even the weight of the pillow to
distort your skull is about a trillion
times stronger than the tidal force of
the moon's gravity across your skull but
no one creates whole whole mystical
predictions about that what about your
pillows good what'd you pill what brand
of pillow you slept with last night yes
so there are very strong ways you can
demonstrate that really there's no
effect on people other than the effect
you think it's supposed to have right
you come out of the bar at 2:00 in the
morning
full moon that's very cool
it's tied to why you rip why you get
shredded as you fall into a black hole
the spaghettification of falling into a
black hole is all because of times
you've fallen see first right a black
hole is small enough so that your height
is gonna make a difference as you fall
in mm-hmm the gravity of your feet
begins to greatly outstrip the gravity
at your head right now your feet are
more attracted to the earth than your
head is okay but spear this is you're
six feet tall that's small compared to
the radius of the earth right a black
hole is small and so when you come down
near a black hole your height is matters
relative to the size of the black hole
so this difference in force grows and
grows until it becomes greater than the
intermolecular force that holds your
flesh together right and then you end up
snare
thing in too likely at the base of the
spine oh god that feels good
well but initially you feel good you say
oh I like stretching who doesn't like a
good stretch right and then you say okay
I had enough pop it no there's two of
you going down those two segments feel
the tidal force and then they snap into
two you go from one to two to four to
eight to 16 but you bifurcate as a
stream of atoms all the way down to the
cosmic of this that's why I'm going into
the black hole cannonball actually I
tried to think this through if you sort
of rotate rotisserie style then it can't
focus on one way to stretch you right so
what what so yeah you might be able to
get a little further in in a cannibal
and I'm rotating okay yeah yeah cool my
summative reflections on this time we've
had together is that I enjoyed it too
wherever in the universe you find
gravity you find tides nice alright you
can see that we're just starting to dip
our toes into the surface of the science
of tides and if you're interested in
learning more about
I don't know gravity's effects on pretty
much everything or how physics affects
our everyday lives or the scientific
phenomena of the moon and what it
doesn't cause hey whether you're science
enthusiasts or a astrophysicist or a
professional or a lifelong learner
brilliant helps you master concepts of
math science and engineering we're
solving fun and challenging problems and
you can sign up for free to get access
to weekly challenges the community
discussions and access to the math and
science wiki and as a bonus to Startalk
viewers the first 782 that go to
brilliant org slash star talk will get
20% off the annual subscription which
helps you think like a scientist right
meal will guide you through course
material the ability to track your
progress with stats and extra practice
if you want to learn more about tides
there's a link in the description which
takes you to the quiz on brilliant on
which this video is based so try it out
I
you want to see more star 12 videos hit
the subscribe button and click the bell
button to get notifications every time
we upload a video and I'll let you have
the last word cuz you always say keep
doing what keep looking up
[Music]
you
[Music]